the mass effect trilogy has been held
with reverence ever since the series
first launched back in 2007
but it's not always been smooth sailing
like with most games it's occasionally
found itself in the headlines
for less than ideal reasons without
further ado here's a timeline of mass
effect's biggest controversies
for more mass effect make sure to like
this video and subscribe
kicking off with mass effects sex scenes
in
early 2008 fox news ran a segment
condemning the sex scenes in the first
mass effect game
claiming that there was full digital
nudity graphic sex and that the player
could decide
exactly what would happen to the two
characters if you know what i mean
you know what i mean anyone who's
actually played mass effect would tell
you that the romance scenes in me1 are
nothing more than a bit of side boob
and maybe some arse a far cry from what
fox were claiming
but nevertheless they brought on author
and psychology expert cooper lawrence
and games journalist jeff keely to
debate the effect that these hardcore
scenes
had on children and while jeff did a
commendable job trying to explain the
truth of the matter
the segment was very anti-mass effect
well i think what's what's interesting
about this we talk about you know
sexuality and media one of the great
things about mass effect for people that
have played it know this this is a
sort of a choose your own adventure
story and it doesn't force you down in
any situation you can actually play
through this game without the sexual
situation ever happening right and the
young boy is going to be choosing not to
have sex that'll be what they'll
it's not a simple choose but cooper it's
not a simple choice you don't turn in
the game it says would you like to have
sex or not
it's through the evolution of a
relationship with characters and the
fact that this game has incredible
artificial intelligence
and you can actually fall in love in
this game and it's the it's just like
modeling your life and i think that's a
much more powerful form of media
i got to go with the research and the
research says there's a new study at a
university of maryland right now that
says that
boys that play video games cannot tell
the difference between
what they're seeing in a video game in
the world if they don't have a real
experience
all right the fallout was immediate and
cooper's book was review bombed on
amazon
not only that but it turns out that
cooper had been set up a bit revealing
to the new york times that she'd been
told by fox producers that the game was
like
pornography eventually most of the
negative reviews from angry mass effect
fans were deleted and she issued a
statement saying that she would have
appreciated the opportunity to play the
game beforehand but she did stick to her
guns when discussing the relationship
between violent
and sexual video games and developing
adolescents this wasn't the only time
that the romancers got the game in hot
water
shortly before its release the game was
banned in singapore by the media
development authority due to the femshep
and liara romance scene
however the decision was quickly
overturned and the ban was lifted the
very next
day and the game was rated m18 the
incident also spurred singapore to
create a classification system for games
so that mature content could be rated
appropriately
lesser controversy and more just sad
that it didn't make it but the
downloadable pack pinnacle station
wasn't a part of the recently released
legendary edition nor was it available
on ps3 when the game
made it to that system because the
source code was lost
pinnacle station was developed by
demiurge studios and not
bioware and despite best efforts to find
copies of the source code
the data was corrupted also pinnacle
station wasn't exactly that beloved so i
think we can all collectively move past
it
moving on to mass effect 2 then a sequel
that expanded upon the original in
numerous ways
more planets to visit reporters to punch
and squadmates to romance
and while there were more same-sex
options for the female commander shepard
there was one who changed
very last minute jack according to an
interview conducted by the gamer with
bioware writer brian kindrigan
jack was essentially pansexual for most
of the development of that romance
however the damning report from fox news
spooked the team and her romance was
changed at the 11th hour
even by the time mass effect 3 rolled
around and both male and female
commander shepard had same-sex romances
jack still remained exclusive to
mailshep but the biggest controversy to
do with an otherwise beloved game
came from its online pass now there's a
term i've not thought about in a long
time but back in 2010 when mass effect 2
launched they were all the rage
when you bought mass effect 2 new you
were given a code that would give you
access to the cerberus network
essentially a storefront for mass effect
2's dlc it would house news new content
and give you a discount on future dlc
however if you were to buy the game
second hand you'd need to drop
15 to get the cerberus network some dlc
like zaid the price of revenge and
normandy crash site were exclusive to
the network but
other bigger packs like lair of the
shadow broker and arrival
were able to be purchased separately
understandably it wasn't very popular
and ea dropped online passes in all its
games completely
in 2013 and of course mass effect 3 was
completely free of controversies
thanks for watching
[Music]
ugh okay let's get into it first up the
fromash's dlc pack it was a huge deal
that we'd finally get to not only meet a
prothean but have one as a squad mate
and so javik's story being added as day
1 dlc definitely stung a bit
it stung even more when people realized
that it was free only if you bought the
collector's edition or digital deluxe
edition of the game and that if you
hadn't
it was ten dollars to buy separately the
stinging
really hurt when it became apparent just
how intrinsically javik is woven into
mass effect 3
and it definitely seemed as though he'd
been cut out for dlc
people were not happy about that and
speaking of squad mates one huge reveal
in mass effect 3 is that of tally's face
the quarian had spent the previous two
games in her enviro suit but if you
followed her romance you could
eventually see what was beneath the mask
except some eagle-eyed players noticed
that her face wasn't exactly
original it was a touched-up stock photo
from getty images there was a very big
outcry at the time and bioware actually
quietly changed her picture in the
legendary edition
and yes people were disappointed with
the ending i'm not gonna go into that
too much
check out our history of mass effect
video for a deeper dive into what
happened there but ultimately bioware
did expand upon the ending with a free
dlc pack called the extended cut
which patched over the most egregious
plot holes and added an extra ending
and some more meat to the three that the
game shipped with which brings us to
andromeda i'm not gonna really talk
about the quality of the game itself too
much it had a turbulent development with
a lot of upheaval within the team and
honestly i find it kind of amazing that
it launched at all
especially given the difficulties with
the engine they were using bioware was
made to pivot to ea's frostbite engine
which could do some things
really really well the driving in that
game is incredible but other things
it couldn't do so well the game launched
in a particularly buggy state and there
was a huge
uproar concerning its facial animations
even leading to a member of the bioware
team being targeted for harassment
after being falsely accused of being
responsible for the wonky animations
the game had multiple additions to
choose from with the two collectors
editions containing either a model of
the game's vehicle
the nomad for 100 or a remote controlled
version for 200
however people got annoyed because
neither version
actually came with the game got the uh
steelbook version of the game which
i'm assuming
awesome did someone steal it
all right so this comes with once again
the uh car mass effect andromeda
steelbook
okay uh-huh
we found it game not included
and finally we'll talk about the lack of
meaningful dlc andromeda ended with the
number of threads left hanging in
particular
to do with the fate of one of the
andromeda initiatives arcs they had
planned to tell that story in dlc
but unfortunately it was cancelled after
the game didn't sell as well as planned
some of those threads were tied up in a
spin-off book however
which brings us to legendary edition now
honestly this one is kind of an
anti-controversy because bioware took
the time to make some tweaks
to things that people had issues with in
the past i already mentioned tally's
face but most notably
they adjusted camera angles to make
things a little less well
full on miranda in particular was memed
to death in mass effect 2 because many
of those camera angles would just really
show off her ass
at her assets
[Music]
legendary edition they changed some of
the camera angles to be a little bit
more
tasteful so there you have it a rundown
of all the biggest moments in mass
effect history
if you're enjoying the legendary edition
make sure to like this video and stick
around on the channel we've got a lot of
videos of mass effect up already
and plenty more on the way you can catch
me on twitter at lucy james games
i should go
[Music]
you